hello freak [ __ ] now you've got a
documentary out that you're working on
as well yeah why it's out now it's
airing on Sunday it's um it's called
hell on earth
it's about the Syrian civil war and the
rise of Isis and it's out on National
Geographic Channel
9:00 Eastern 8:00 central this Sunday
this Sunday um is it going to be
available I mean you can obviously watch
it at the time but it's going to be
available on Netflix or Apple TV or
something like that well I think I'll
know that yeah yeah it's um I haven't
even thought that far ahead I mean it's
owned by National Geographic so I don't
know quite know how they I'm sure you'll
be able to get it on their website at
some point but it's airing on Sunday and
what was your experience doing that well
I you know I was home writing tribe
actually and so I wasn't overseas and
you couldn't really get into Syria
anyway I mean it was a suicidal thing to
do and so what we did my colleague Nick
the guy who was here earlier we
basically sort of worked the border
border areas around Syria looking for
people who were living in Syria who knew
people in Syria who could shoot for us
and we found some very very brave people
who documented their lives under Isis
their lives with the Free Syrian Army
there was a lot of combat and we
accumulated about an hour a thousand
hours of footage and interviews we did
with experts and we put together hell on
earth trying to explain how really quite
peaceful democratic protests turn into
violent demonstrations that finally into
a civil war and of course it's the it
was the repressive government I mean
people protest in the street and they're
met with machine-gun fire and eventually
civilians are going to get some machine
guns themselves and fight back and
that's how you get a civil war how do
you take thousands of hours like that
and boil it down to one show well that's
it's very very hard I mean that's what
filmmaking is and it's figuring out
what's the one percent that goes into
the film and how do i structure it how
much time does it take to do something
yet really good I mean this is the first
I've made this is my fifth film most of
the films I've made it was me and an
editor and so another person in the room
or whatever this we had a big team and
so we had some very very smart young
people who were going through all this
footage and cat
arising it like here this is a section
about you know this material is about
whatever escaping Isis and this is about
trying to find you know whatever they
would they would sort of put it into
categories and then I would start to
look through some of that material and
could gradually sort of build a build a
structure the the situation in Syria
seems to be for someone who just hasn't
studied it that much but just looks at
it from the outside one of the bleaker
darker situations that we have here in
the world i mean it's the tragedy
tragedy of this generation I think over
400,000 Syrians mostly civilians have
died the equivalent equivalent death
toll in this country would be I think
seven or eight million Americans the
equivalent amount of people and and half
the country half of the Syrian
population has been displaced from their
homes and millions millions are you know
outside the country's borders in Europe
and and even in this country when did
you take out on a documentary I mean it
seems like no one has a solution for
Syria no I mean civil wars are tough
that way
I think Isis Isis eventually is going to
be defeated on the battlefield they're
going to be eradicated and I hope they
are because they're in ghastly brutal
group and Assad who is who was killed
way more people than Isis he just didn't
do it publicly like they did he's the
leader of Syria president of Syria
he's propped up by Iran and by Russia
and so he's not going anywhere I mean if
you have those two countries as your
allies like you're not going anywhere so
I think what's going to happen
ultimately is the ISIS will be defeated
and the country will be partitioned
along sectarian lines and they're
eventually there may be a kind of a
delicate peace it seems like with all
those Middle Eastern countries well but
any country that's run by a brutal
dictator as soon as that dictators
removed or as soon as somebody dies
there's this massive power vacuum yeah
yeah I mean that would be the argument
for not trying to remove him I mean he's
a grind lead criminal and sadist and
he's horrible but what was the argument
for keeping so
saying in power it was the argument for
keeping Gaddafi in power yeah I mean
basically it sort of utilitarian
argument as from John Stuart Mill like
what's going to what's going to cause
the least human suffering or promote the
most human happiness and and you know I
sometimes I can understand the reasoning
behind look the guy's a dictator but we
should leave them in place because the
alternative is a lot of other innocent
people suffering when we remove him in
the country collapses this country has
already collapsed so the projects of the
question is okay we make a tentative
peace deal with him we'll leave you in
power we won't try to topple you but
let's stop fighting I mean I can I I
could support that yeah personally Wow
isn't that crazy the idea of keeping
that guy in power yes so less people
suffer you keep a brutal murderous
dictator in power yeah and I better off
that way yeah well I mean you know the
war killed almost half a million people
yeah if you want that to continue like
well yeah that's I mean those are the
awful moral choices it's very
frustrating for people though because
they would like to see like dude we'd
like to see some solution like on the
tape but that doesn't seem like us or
well well it's a solution to the
violence right I mean I NEP any peace
deal is a solution to the violence so
the first thing that has to happen I
think is that the violence stop so that
people stop dying the pursuit of justice
is the secondary is important but it's a
secondary matter after that
you